Choiszt: 那个房间门要打开
Choiszt: That room door needs to be opened.
Alice: 一楼扫完了吗
Alice: Is the first floor cleaned?
Jake:扫完了
Jake: It's cleaned.
Jake: 那个你可以
Jake: You can...
Jake: 反正反正
Jake: Anyway, anyway...
Alice:好累哦
Alice: So tired.
Tasha: 把事給干了
Tasha: Get things done.
Alice: 我再也不想刷了
Alice: I never want to scrub again.
Alice:全是这个味
Alice: It all smells the same.
Katrina:  你的灯灭了耶
Katrina: Your light went out.
Tasha: 是的嘞
Tasha: Yes, it did.
Katrina: 你灯灭了
Katrina: Your light went out.
Alice: 我这有充电的呢
Alice: I have a charger here.
Katrina: 没事就算了吧
Katrina: Never mind, just forget it.
Katrina:  哎又亮了
Katrina: Oh, it lit up again.
Katrina:  哦不对那是他的反光
Katrina: Oh no, that's just a reflection.
Katrina:  对不起哈哈
Katrina: Sorry, haha.
Alice: 给
Alice: Here.
Katrina:  哎呀
Katrina: Oh no.
Alice:有
Alice: Yes.
Alice: 给你有线没
Alice: Do you have a cable?
Lucia: 没有我线好像也在
Lucia: No, I think my cable is also...
Alice: 线是不是也是通用的吗
Alice: Aren't the cables universal?
Tasha: 是通用的
Tasha: They are universal.
Lucia: 谢谢你要不要看一下你还有多少电
Lucia: Thanks. Do you want to check how much battery you have left?
Alice:我充了好久
Alice: I've been charging for a long time.
Alice: 我还有77
Alice: I still have 77%.
Katrina: 公园能干啥去野餐啊
Katrina: What can we do in the park? Picnic?
Shure: 溜达
Shure: Stroll around.
Shure: 公园可以压马路
Shure: You can take a walk in the park.
Lucia: 啊我好像不是没电了我是没内存了
Lucia: Ah, I think it's not that I'm out of battery, I'm out of memory.
Alice: 你是没删吗
Alice: Didn't you delete anything?
Lucia: 我们今天上午的这个不是
Lucia: Not the stuff from this morning.
Lucia: 下午就是三点多的那个
Lucia: It's the stuff from around 3 PM.
Lucia: 可以删掉了吗
Lucia: Can I delete it?
Alice:对
Alice: Yeah.
Lucia: 没事没事我不是没电了
Lucia: It's okay, it's okay, it's not the battery.
Lucia: 他是没内存了
Lucia: It's out of memory.
Lucia: 但是今天下午的那个应该已经导过了吧
Lucia: But the stuff from this afternoon should be already transferred, right?
Choiszt:  反正先留着吧我不太清楚导没导
Choiszt: Just keep it for now, I'm not sure if it's transferred.
Lucia:  我把三点钟那个删了
Lucia: I'll delete the 3 PM one.
Lucia: 应该导过一次然后我们晚上又拿到了那个
Lucia: It should have been transferred once, and then we got it again in the evening.
Tasha: 晚上录之前都把删掉了
Tasha: Delete everything before recording in the evening.
Choiszt: 这个你先拿着你的已经删了是吗
Choiszt: Did you delete yours already?
Tasha: 嗯唉
Tasha: Yeah, I did.
Tasha: 实用性和应用价值
Tasha: Practicality and application value.
Katrina:  哎他是不是要
Katrina: Hey, does he need...
Katrina:  他是不是少了散粉啊噢噢
Katrina: Is he missing loose powder? Oh, oh.
Katrina:  哦对定妆喷雾
Katrina: Oh right, setting spray.
Nicous: 什么叫散粉哦等一下她给我讲了一个
Nicous: What is loose powder? Oh, wait, she explained it to me.
Alice: 你还用吗
Alice: Do you still need it?
Katrina:  你喝酒他抽烟
Katrina: You drink, he smokes.
Nicous: 你要撤是吗
Nicous: Are you leaving?
Lucia: 我把我这个先充上万一
Lucia: I'll charge this up just in case.
Katrina:  你会抽烟
Katrina: You smoke?
Katrina:  你会啊
Katrina: You do?
Nicous:  老板请享用
Nicous: Boss, enjoy.
Katrina:  哎呀哎呀哎呀
Katrina: Oh my, oh my.
Katrina:  你这下真成那种摇
Katrina: Now you're really rocking it.
Katrina:  滚的了就是
Katrina: Like a rock star.
Katrina:  哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Katrina:  很厉害很厉害
Katrina: Impressive, impressive.
Shure:  这也没有爆珠吧
Shure: There's no menthol, right?
Nicous: 有爆珠有爆珠食活爆珠
Nicous: There is menthol, there is menthol.
Katrina:  哈哈眼影盘
Katrina: Haha, eyeshadow palette.
Nicous:  他说他自己买的妆前
Nicous: He said he bought his own primer.
Nicous:  妆前和隔离
Nicous: Primer and base.
Nicous:  嗯对那是散粉
Nicous: Yeah, that's loose powder.
Katrina:  那是用在粉底液之前的
Katrina: That's used before foundation.
Nicous: 你有散粉吗
Nicous: Do you have loose powder?
Katrina:  不是你这也太贴心了
Katrina: Wow, you’re so considerate.
Katrina:  看见别人的幸福我就破防
Katrina: Seeing other people's happiness just gets to me.
Katrina:  你知道吗
Katrina: You know?
Shure:  嘿嘿破防吧你就
Shure: Haha, it really gets to you, huh?
Katrina:  今天真让我大破防啊
Katrina: Today has really hit me hard.
Katrina:  本来开开心心
Katrina: I was so happy at first.
Nicous: 我来给你介绍好了
Nicous: Let me introduce someone to you.
Katrina:  长得帅的
Katrina: A handsome one?
Nicous: 没问题
Nicous: No problem.
Nicous: 有长得帅的我就发给你
Nicous: If I find a handsome one, I'll send him to you.
Katrina:  我在我们武汉理工呆四年
Katrina: I stayed at Wuhan University of Technology for four years.
Katrina:  没见到一个帅哥
Katrina: Never saw a single handsome guy.
Katrina:  倒也不是眼光高
Katrina: It's not like my standards are high.
Nicous: 你需要多高的
Nicous: How tall do you need him to be?
Katrina:  一米八
Katrina: 1.8 meters.
Lucia: 哦那个五点的也可以删了好的
Lucia: Oh, you can delete the 5 PM one too, okay.
Katrina:  我靠
Katrina: Oh my god.
Katrina:  给你拍张艺术照
Katrina: Let me take an artistic photo of you.
Nicous:  不够有万宝路
Nicous: Not enough, you need Marlboro.
Shure:  可以可以可以
Shure: Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Katrina:  私下烟酒都来呀
Katrina: You even smoke and drink in private?
Katrina:  哈哈哈特别像我一个表弟
Katrina: Hahaha, you look just like one of my cousins.
Shure:  哎你们都不喝
Shure: Hey, you guys aren’t drinking?
Katrina:  再喝晚上还写毕设呢
Katrina: If I drink more, I still have to write my thesis tonight.
Shure:  几点了哥
Shure: What time is it, man?
Shure:  10点了还写毕设呢
Shure: It’s 10 PM and you’re still working on your thesis?
Katrina:  那没别的时间呀
Katrina: I don’t have any other time.
Katrina:  早上起不来
Katrina: I can't get up in the morning.
Katrina:  只有晚上工作
Katrina: I can only work at night.
Shure:  明天早上我叫你
Shure: I'll wake you up tomorrow morning.
Shure:  咱俩一起写毕设
Shure: We’ll write the thesis together.
Katrina:  好吧
Katrina: Alright.
Katrina:  几点钟
Katrina: What time?
Shure:  8点钟起写毕设
Shure: 8 AM, start writing the thesis.
Shure:  你写不写
Shure: Are you in?
Katrina:  我靠
Katrina: Oh my god.
Shure: 我现在
Shure: I’m serious.
Shure:  咱再来一杯
Shure: Let’s have another drink.
Shure:  然后咱8点起来写毕设
Shure: Then we’ll get up at 8 AM to write the thesis.
Shure:  好吧
Shure: Alright?
Katrina:  不
Katrina: No.
Katrina:  坚定原则
Katrina: Stick to principles.
Shure:  咦好坚定
Shure: Wow, very determined.
Katrina:  等我今天把事弄完了
Katrina: Let me finish my work today.
Katrina:  明天跟你喝
Katrina: We can drink tomorrow.
Katrina:  今天是第几天
Katrina: What day is it today?
Katrina:  第第二天第三天
Katrina: Second, third day?
Katrina:  还早着呢
Katrina: It's still early.
Katrina:  明天还要拍那个yesok
Katrina: We need to shoot that yesok tomorrow.
Katrina:  yesok
Katrina: yesok.
Katrina:  你今天晚上去学
Katrina: Go learn it tonight.
Katrina:  你来教行吗
Katrina: Can you teach me?
Katrina:  不想教
Katrina: I don't want to teach.
Shure:  我可以给你查拍子
Shure: I can help you keep the beat.
Shure:  我查拍子绝对牛逼
Shure: I'm really good at it.
Shure:  我跟你讲
Shure: I'm telling you.
Nicous: 你他妈也太浪费钱了吧
Nicous: You’re wasting money like crazy.
Nicous: 抽这么一点就扔你是人吗
Nicous: You smoke a little and then toss it, are you even human?
Shure:  怎么遭哇
Shure: What’s the problem?
Katrina:  怎么着吧打一架
Katrina: What now, wanna fight?
Katrina:  其实我觉得这个地方完全可以翻进来
Katrina: Actually, I think we can totally sneak in here.
Katrina:  这里又没有门又没有密码
Katrina: There's no door or password here.
Katrina:  哦也是你们帮忙挑的
Katrina: Oh, you guys helped pick this place too?
Katrina:  他的优势是
Katrina: His advantage is...
Nicous: 两个客厅大
Nicous: Two big living rooms.
Nicous:  公共区域比较大
Nicous: The common areas are pretty spacious.
Nicous: 他还有一个优势是每个人住的地方比较大
Nicous: Another advantage is that everyone's living space is quite big.
Katrina:  嗯我当时
Katrina: Hmm, back then...
Katrina:  我当时一直以为是三个人住一个房间
Katrina: I always thought it was three people to a room.
Nicous:  差点让你们三个人住一个房间
Nicous: Almost had you three sharing a room.
Shure:  为什么不是三个人住一个房间
Shure: Why not three people in one room?
Nicous:  那你就跟杨老板住一个房间
Nicous: Then you'd be sharing with Jake.
Nicous:  不是三个人是两两
Nicous: It's not three, it's two each.
Katrina:  他5点睡
Katrina: He goes to bed at 5.
Katrina:  你几点睡
Katrina: What time do you sleep?
Shure:  我以为是跟女嘉宾住一个房间
Shure: I thought I was sharing a room with the female guest.
Katrina:  这话赶紧给他录下来
Katrina: Quick, record that!
Katrina:  给他女朋友发过去
Katrina: Send it to his girlfriend.
Shure:  你滚犊子吧你
Shure: Get lost, you!
Shure:  嗯
Shure: Hmm.
Shure:  哎你知道吗
Tasha: 并强调了
Tasha: And emphasized...
Shure:  我我们俩
Shure: We... both of us...
Shure:  我俩五一一一起回长春你知道吗
Shure: We're both going back to Changchun together for May Day, you know?
Katrina:  那这不得见一波家长啊
Katrina: So, you have to meet the parents, right?
Nicous: 所以酒喝多了都可以说了
Nicous: So, after a few drinks, everything comes out?
Shure:  你知道这个小红帽子梗吗
Shure: Do you know the Little Red Riding Hood joke?
Katrina:  啊我室友也是
Katrina: Oh, my roommate too...
Katrina:  就是男生的妈妈来找他
Katrina: It's when the guy's mom comes to find him...
Nicous: 因为她不理我了
Nicous: Because she ignores me...
Katrina:  对就是
Katrina: Yeah, exactly.
Katrina:  但是但是
Katrina: But, but...
Katrina:  这样子的话也有有好也有不好
Katrina: In that case, there are pros and cons.
Katrina:  那要是你以后换女朋友
Katrina: So, if you get a new girlfriend...
Katrina:  你妈不得哄下一个
Katrina: Your mom has to win over the next one too.
Tasha: 旅游发展领悟
Tasha: Tourism development insights...
Shure:  我本我本来买的那个杭州
Shure: I originally bought the one to Hangzhou...
Tasha: 这篇论文提出了问题
Tasha: This paper raises issues...
Katrina:  你女朋友啊
Katrina: Your girlfriend?
Katrina:  哎呀你们俩够抽象的
Katrina: Wow, you two are so abstract.
Katrina:  不是你你们俩
Katrina: No, I mean you two...
Katrina:  呃你们俩就那个软件上认识以后
Katrina: Uh, you two met on that app, and then...
Katrina:  那见面了吗
Katrina: Did you meet in person?
Katrina:  然后见面就表白在一起了
Katrina: And then you confessed and got together?
Tasha: 具体的开发
Tasha: The specific development...
Katrina:  他给你写的
Katrina: He wrote it for you?
Katrina:  唉哈哈
Katrina: Haha...
Katrina:  感觉每个人的事情都很神奇
Katrina: It feels like everyone's story is so amazing.
Tasha: 结合文章深度
Tasha: Combined with the depth of the article...
Katrina:  那就是见面了的时候
Katrina: So when you met...
Katrina:  就互相彼此心动了呗
Katrina: You both fell for each other?
Katrina:  看对眼了呗
Katrina: You just clicked?
Katrina:  哦确实一开始就眼熟嘛
Katrina: Oh, it's true, you found each other familiar right from the start.
Katrina:  你不是说很抽象吗你这个
Katrina: Didn't you say it was very abstract?
Katrina:  特别喜欢听别人讲八卦
Katrina: I love listening to gossip.
Katrina:  因为我在学校圈子其实就我舍
Katrina: Because in my school circle, it's just my dorm...
Katrina:  友然后我舍友几个要么就有男朋友
Katrina: My dorm mates either have boyfriends...
Katrina:  一直高中谈到现在
Katrina: They've been dating since high school...
Katrina:  要么就是不跟男的说一句话
Katrina: Or they don't talk to guys at all.
Katrina:  就没有没有八卦就是我说我
Katrina: So, there's no gossip, I mean, like...
Katrina:  我在学校里圈子比较小
Katrina: My social circle at school is pretty small.
Katrina:  就没听见什么八卦
Katrina: So, I don't hear any gossip.
Katrina:  我们哎太喜欢认识新的人了
Katrina: We really love meeting new people.
Shure:  我们想想听你的八卦
Shure: We want to hear your gossip.
Katrina:  我就一段
Katrina: I have just one story.
Nicous: 说宝宝早安
Nicous: Say, "Good morning, babe."
Nicous:  然后第二天就跟我前女友奔现了
Nicous: Then the next day, he met up with my ex-girlfriend.
Katrina:  谁谁谁谁
Katrina: Who? Who? Who?
Nicous:  我刚说的第二天说宝宝早安
Nicous: The next day after I said, "Good morning, babe."
Nicous:  第二天就跟我前女友有奔现了
Nicous: The next day, he met up with my ex-girlfriend.
Katrina:  你
Katrina: You...
Katrina:  你跟你前女友官宣
Katrina: You announced it with your ex-girlfriend?
Katrina:  暧昧
Katrina: An affair?
Nicous:  一开始暧昧
Nicous: It started as an affair.
Nicous:  后来已经g了
Nicous: Then we just hit it off.
Nicous:  后来他私信不理我
Nicous: Later, he ignored my DMs.
Nicous:  他说他在忙
Nicous: He said he was busy.
Nicous:  然后我以为我跟他就是朋友处了
Nicous: Then I thought we were just friends.
Nicous:  然后我就直接跟
Nicous: And then I just...
Nicous:  然后后来就跟我前女友认识了
Nicous: Then I met my ex-girlfriend.
Nicous:  就是不认识了
Nicous: We just lost touch.
Katrina:  也就是说
Katrina: So, you mean...
Katrina:  你跟你现女友认识的比你前女友早
Katrina: You met your current girlfriend before your ex-girlfriend?
Nicous: 早太多了
Nicous: Way before.
Nicous:  然后然后我就直接发过来
Nicous: Then I just sent it over directly.
Nicous:  我也没隐瞒他我就他看见了
Nicous: I didn't hide it, he saw it.
Nicous:  然后他就说好吧然后
Nicous: Then he said, "Alright, then."
Tasha: 好吧
Tasha: Okay.
Katrina:  哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Nicous:  过了一段时间过了一段时间
Nicous: After some time...
Nicous:  他买了个机票直接来北京
Nicous: He bought a ticket and came straight to Beijing.
Nicous:  他然后他到了晚上跟我讲他到了
Nicous: Then at night, he told me he arrived.
Nicous:  让我晚上出来接他
Nicous: Asked me to pick him up.
Katrina:  但是那时你分手了吗
Katrina: But had you broken up by then?
Nicous:  没分的我刚来北京
Nicous: No, we hadn't. I just got to Beijing.
Nicous:  然后关键最惆怅的是我他妈睡着了
Nicous: The worst part is, I fell asleep.
Nicous:  没看见嗯我刚起来他飞走了吧哦
Nicous: Didn't see him. When I woke up, he had already left.
Tasha: 啊
Tasha: What?
Katrina:  但是我觉得这女生还蛮有勇气的
Katrina: But I think that girl was pretty brave.
Nicous:  然后后来就都互删了
Nicous: And then later we just deleted each other.
Katrina:  互删了后来又加上了
Katrina: Deleted each other but then added back again.
Nicous:  后来我女朋友老出轨
Nicous: Later my girlfriend kept cheating.
Nicous:  我就不想跟我女朋友谈了
Nicous: I didn't want to be with my girlfriend anymore.
Nicous:  但是我就把他加回来了
Nicous: But I added him back.
Nicous:  然后但是那时候没想跟他谈恋爱
Nicous: But at that time, I didn't think of dating him.
Nicous:  我一直都是加回来了
Nicous: I just added him back.
Nicous:  然后抱歉一下干嘛
Nicous: Then I apologized for it.
Katrina:  但是你那也有点像就
Katrina: But you kinda made it look like...
Katrina:  在他的视角有点像断崖式暧昧耶
Katrina: From his perspective, it was like a sudden cliff of flirting.
Katrina:  就是本来暧昧很好的然后突然跟别人
Katrina: It was all good flirting, then suddenly you were with someone else.
Katrina:  四天四天就能代表什么
Katrina: Four days, what can that represent?
Shure:  四天我这四年里
Shure: Four days, I had four years of it.
Katrina:  我这五年的
Katrina: I had five years of it.
Shure:  不喝点了吗
Shure: Didn't we drink a bit?
Shure:  雨轩
Shure: Yuxuan.
Katrina:  你给我整点呗
Katrina: Get me some.
Shure:  给你整点
Shure: I'll get you some.
Katrina:  你当心他进去了
Katrina: Be careful with him going in.
Nicous: 当时我加他的时候我就跟他说了
Nicous: When I added him back, I told him.
Katrina:  他家很有钱吗
Katrina: Is his family really rich?
Katrina:  我去那确实有点啊
Katrina: When I went there, it was a bit like that.
Katrina:  那确实
Katrina: Yeah, indeed.
Katrina:  那你这飞机飞来飞去
Katrina: You were just flying back and forth.
Katrina:  嗯
Katrina: Hmm.
Katrina:  就是在一直就跟他在一起
Katrina: Just always being together with him.
Katrina:  就是我靠你都同居还能出轨哈哈哈
Katrina: I mean, damn, you were living together and still cheating, haha.
Katrina:  我靠你给我少搞一点点
Katrina: Damn, give me a break.
Katrina:  你前女友是表演型人格吗
Katrina: Was your ex-girlfriend a histrionic personality?
Katrina:  啊你俩谁也不缺啊
Katrina: Ah, neither of you lacked anything.
Katrina:  他分了你也分了
Katrina: He broke up and you broke up.
Katrina:  然后你俩在一起了
Katrina: Then you two got together.
Katrina:  怎么不算一种缘分呢
Katrina: How is that not a kind of fate?
Katrina:  我靠你给我搞这么多东西
Katrina: Damn, you gave me so much stuff.
Katrina:  晚上要一直上厕所
Katrina: I’ll be going to the bathroom all night.
Katrina:  看柚子好不好喝哈
Katrina: Let's see if the pomelo juice is good.
Katrina:  哎还行
Katrina: Oh, not bad.
Katrina:  感觉比橙汁好喝
Katrina: Tastes better than orange juice.
Tasha: 烦死了
Tasha: So annoying.